okay four people joining this livestream
this is part of our endless series
meetings about incremental improvements
to oven language so this was about need
to discuss how to control display of
numerical precision okay yeah so here's
a here's an issue that I run into quite
regularly
okay so I'll get you know something
where I'll say you know I don't know
what but what's a good example um
okay they're there I've got something
reasonable but let's say I make this
into input form
when I met what happened there am i
confused well copy that I paste it I'm
still getting something like that well
how do I get what I'm the I find myself
too often I've got some input
I'll it here let's say I say I'm
something like this I is this gonna do
it and I say something like that analyst
yeah there we go it's a good example
okay but I really don't want that in my
input because I really you know I just
got that number out but I I just need
the approximate number I just need that
okay but there's no easy way for me to
get that but you want to change the
display I would assume the display yes I
think it's primarily the display I mean
I think this is the analog of I can eyes
for a number I know we've got some
background noise there okay yeah that's
probably the way to say it it's the
analog of I can eyes for a number
because I mean this number you need to
carry it around like that like like if I
do the output here okay so that will be
a more civilized number but maybe I only
want two digits there and I don't have a
good way to say that I mean I think we
have to even have that precision what is
it called isn't there there used to be a
print precision option somewhere I don't
even have to even have that there's also
I think a system option in the kernel
land so it gets really confusing that's
really confusing and I mean here in
preferences I think that we have a
number there we go
yeah I mean number of digits displayed
an output but that's like a totally
obscure place to put this and that's a
global setting which is not what we want
here
I mean more what I would want is
something that's the analog of icon eyes
here where I can just say you know it's
almost like I don't know what the right
term is but it's some show only a few
digits of this number and go ahead I was
thinking that this may be related to s
it is I think I mean so that so let's
let's do an example of that so if I say
[Music]
right I mean it's it's a bit like this
yeah I agree and I mean it would need a
it might need some kind of graphical
indication that there's more there I
don't think it would want to be boxed
like this um what does this do in
traditional form I see okay fair enough
um yeah I mean you know so what I would
expect is I can either select the whole
cell and then do a right-click and say
this and alternatively just like I could
say you know I can eyes that cell I
could say about that cell display it
yeah this is a display directive so this
would be something like um what would be
the right term I mean this isn't you
know so here if I say this comma 3 for
example okay that will give but I
what that's doing is that is really
precision three right right I mean
there's a number form okay so this is
really what I'm talking about is number
form but I'm suppose I'm talking about a
number form where at least with
mouse-over
you can tell that there's more to this
number which is going to appear very
soon is in quantity with these new
constants that are exact so we are going
to get now fractions ugly fractions
perhaps people will want to see with
some decimals but we're still going to
keep inside the fractions yes yes that's
something that we could do in quantity
right but I mean I think here my point
is you know way too often I mean okay
look there's two cases that I want
sometimes I'll get out some messy number
and I'm trying to think about a use case
for that but there plenty of cases where
I've gotten out some messy thing like
this but it's sufficient to just say
three point one that's actually what I
want that's what I genuinely want the
number to be you know like I'll give you
an example yeah I'll give you an example
let's say I'm showing a fit okay so
let's say I say you know fit two
okay so I might very well want the thing
that I'm giving to just be 0.6 plus X
plus plus 0.1 7x squared okay because it
turns out that that full digits and that
fit just aren't relevant that this is as
good a a fit to the data as this would
be but this is something that I can you
know in a civilized way to show to
somebody that makes sense you mean the
the actual numbers here right because
here we do have methods to control the
actual positions that these numbers have
so you're saying there should be a fit
around that gives the round numbers back
I see you know we should have a fit
around I love that idea right that gives
this this thing what's that way of
turning some functions into our own
functions and introduce something
compute okay although I would prefer
this by default to do that because I
think this is the this is a much better
result is to give the around result and
to give this results but okay but so
that's another case is the case where
you actually just want the numbers so
your point is I mean can I can I
simulate that for myself here how would
I would I something like that to get
that fit with an around well I think
linear model fit for example has
information about arrows
so if I just say linear model fit of
this doesn't suit you're very happy this
is a complicated function okay yeah okay
well that sure doesn't have a nice nice
thing right but this insight has
information about errors I mean never
remember how to extract it okay so fit
residuals oh boy okay lots of
complicated stuff yeah okay but fine but
there's some way to do it and so the
first thing we should add is one of
these weird extractors that will return
this formula but in a in a way that has
around in it um right I know
a point being made on the live stream is
that number form doesn't work in
calculations indeed and we want
something that does number form is
purely a display thing but but so in the
case of these numbers what would end up
happening I don't think I mean precision
is the only way that we're tracking the
genuine number of digits we get out so
if it was one of these sort of less less
displayed numbers that would only be
relevant for input or output or wherever
you select this I mean so so let's
imagine that the thing said is something
like um number display not a very good
term but but you know let's say it was a
number display comma n um and that that
produced this thing that could
potentially be a mouse-over let's see
the lifestream sander is sending us a
piece of code here
let's take a look that's kind of cool
yeah that's cool I mean obviously it's
got to be something that evaporates on
evaluation so it's got to be purely a
display thing but that's not that's not
a difficult thing to handle I mean so
similarly here I'm sure that if I do n
of percent 10 that will all evaporate um
yeah it's got to it's got to be a number
for purposes of everything other than
its display exactly so I mean it but it
works using I mean just like defer for
example can give you a way no I want
some interpretation yeah right right
right right
so interpretation would be so we could
write this displays as e but its value
is in this case n of Pi right so if I
now take that and I say that Bluff well
I didn't do the right thing if I say
this thing and I copy that and I then
give that well that's really weird
did I get this wrong way around displays
a Z but is interpreted as the unev alyou
ated if suppliers input um oh yeah that
did work that way yeah yeah what goofed
up here yeah that works perfectly
what goofed up here was simply that this
flip view wasn't wasn't tongue hardened
for being shown as an input cell um
so ah let's see um have a number Foreman
round in the suggestions bar that is a
that is a perfectly decent suggestion I
don't think we do that right now do we
if I say increase precision shoul digits
but we don't have yeah we don't have
this we don't have make it a two-digit
thing or whatever else and that would be
another sensible thing to do I think
just affecting me at the display I think
so think so
yeah yeah I mean I think that that um I
mean I just you know it's just like like
I want to emphasize again that what does
this do that is an interpretation and
now I do this and that has a tooltip
which gives the number okay and I paste
it in it still for some bizarre reason
it's putting the quotes there but it's
basically yeah right
that's the that's the object that can
turn it into a thing that displays on
it's two digits um I mean I think the
thing that I want again is to be able to
use this you know numbered display icon
ization thing to take an object like
that and have it be displayed with I
mean I'm sure if I take that and I say
number form of percent 16 comma - yeah
it looks like that well that's a little
bit unpleasant but that's okay and now
if I'm writing my computational essay
and I say you know the fit is roughly
you know and then I then I paste this in
well okay some god what the heck is
going on there
that's really goofy but that's what
number form does see yeah I mean so
that's something that we if we can fix
that then we've come a long way to
fixing this well it would I don't know
how we implement it but I mean you could
wrap the whole thing and it would do
this to everything all right so look I
think I think I've defined this maybe we
can have a separate think about how this
might work but I think that the basic
point is it's some number display thing
that would also be in the right-click
menu that effects the display of numbers
in something but does not affect their
values and that has an indication
probably that the number continues some
little tiny gray dots or something that
the number continues that gets a little
iffy because it will probably round
rather than floor and that's probably
what we why I see what you're saying
yeah that's a good point how does that
work in the I mean okay so let's take a
concrete example so the thing says one
point nine nine nine nine nine and if I
were to do this okay so I have that oh
that's interesting okay nines that's so
confusing okay and now I say number form
that comma two and it's gonna say two
which is correct it is correct but how
would we give an indication that a
number is a this is not what it's what I
mean at some level this is not what it
seems either so I mean who's who cares I
guess you could have something like a
plus minus dot dot dot in gray or
something but you can't just have dot
dot dot yeah I understand but I mean
look this is already dishonest in the
sense because there's already more
digits there right so I think the answer
is you don't show anything else you
might do a tooltip but you don't show
anything else I'm fine with that
all right so we have to figure out how
to insert how to kind of have something
that yeah that doesn't have this
goofiness with with the strings so if
you guys could think about that that
would be terrific okay should we go on I
think we should do it in the definition
box I think that's a historical thing of
some minority weird cases I mean I think
except in cases that we're sort of
embarrassed about um the yeah
yeah it's just dumb I mean you could
just take that and put that up here
right so I mean there are two things
coming to the documentation which you
need to which is structural like this
one is well this one I've noticed but
there are but um the other case is these
things where it says for the options for
this function go see another function
those drive me crazy and I want to just
you know suck that stuff in um okay we
have some code here sandir something
else as well nice and those are you know
this kook
is interesting it's interesting now
notice that around is a one-way clicker
doesn't it's a zero a clicker it doesn't
it doesn't okay so at that point we lost
the sorry the I can eyes thing so it's
an interesting question whether having a
flip view type idea before I can eyes
might do worthwhile
well so why doesn't I cannot have a
tooltip yeah I have to say
of the mm-hmm I wonder whether there
should be something where you press
where you click this and you get a still
boxed I can eyes thing do you see what
I'm saying
so in other words let's let's say you've
got some options to some function okay
so I say plot sine X X 0 10 you know
filling arrow access filling style arrow
yellow you know frame arrow true etc and
let's say I recognize this okay so now
clicking doesn't do anything on that yes
so in LCC meeting last week we discussed
about making that clickable and John
mentioned that there is this selection
thingy that is coming and we'll have it
one of the things that we'll have that
we will have in the selection bar is
editing the names right okay but but I'm
suggesting something else which I'm
actually thinking is quite interesting
which is the ability to if you click it
to get an icon ization but in a box what
do i mean by that what I mean by that is
to see what's inside the ionised thing
but maintaining a box so that if you
click on it again it will become ionized
again right so you want to see what are
the options to this plot okay I want to
see them but actually I want them
ionized again without having to go back
and you know go back into the go back
and we select them and so on
yeah like appeal you yes yes I think we
should consider I hadn't thought of this
before
we would see only a few elements don't
know possibly yes don't be a reasonable
way to do it um can we consider that
and senatorial sissies is that what
we're talking about like a nice because
yes yeah okay head man this is a
discussion of the next point which is
that we have discussed we have discussed
in previous meetings so this is
motivation one more reason to have it in
system is because we were doubting
whether to have it in system or not so
can we go back a bit the idea is that
the next point is about the Korean
language and normal of a query converts
into what Ali calls a compiled form and
some cases in some cases these compiled
form uses general utilities function Oh
horrifying one of those is applied
through which happens to be our head map
and one thing of this apply through
which hasn't thought before about is
that it works with associations and
that's quite useful for leaders at work
so these Alex this is how we could use
head map inside dataset that's useful
okay hold on hold on hold on I have
never been a big fan of this query
function yes well I knew this was gonna
come right when we invented these I knew
we were gonna end up having to do this
and one of the things I wanted to
discuss with you is how to how to modify
the documentation of data set which is
totally bizarre right now yeah I mean
one problem is because data set I mean
so one question is there are functions
other functions that have a life inside
data set but we're documenting every
aspect of those other functions let's
say catenate or something inside data
set we're not documenting that
as a you know as a feature of catenate
we're documenting it as a feature of
data set right okay so here's a weird
idea okay what if we had a family of
documentation that is basically the data
set query you know that's about data set
queries and that has essentially a page
for catenate for instance so it becomes
something where we can point to that
from the catenate function and then we
can essentially have a guide page of
those things from data set extended and
explained with the whole bunch is that
it is a function a standard function in
the system that has been kind of not
really hijacked but um you know you know
it's been used inside data set in a way
that is basically a bit of a turning
head heads out inside out type thing
relative to the way it's usually used I
was talking about the use of catenate in
query okay but but so query is in my
opinion is just an alternative way of
accessing data side there is this
identity there they said some charlatan
okay is that right
true modulo the fact that sometimes
they're the object comes back with I
think it's self is concerned but he's
writing book that use dataset a lot and
he likes query don't break it we won't
break it don't worry okay so is that
this identity is true is that right
sometimes the second the right hand side
would return things with dataset all
without it on the left hand side there's
never return straight is that in general
an association or a list of options etc
so query will not add by itself we start
with a dataset and sometimes the dataset
head is lost but typically it's
preserved okay yes so I'm trying to find
a way to explain clearly what's going on
with this query language in dataset
which in my opinion is an extension of
the part extraction language to also
support function application I think we
should send this notebook to self it
might help them um although he's
probably figured it all out by now um
okay so in this first example for
example the Diaz case there yes so there
we have a mixture in the second line of
two functional applications and a part
extraction the three so the question is
always the same in which orders do this
thing happens and at which level are
these functions yes
so what I'm saying here is that the way
I understand these things is by
separating them into individual
operations like in different parts of
brackets what you have on the right mmm
you see what's happening what's
happening for each of them for this
first extraction for G and for F and in
which order they are being used and
standing on descending is fundamental
when deciding those two things the order
okay but I mean in this notation
how do i doesn't this notation mean
you're always applying it at the front
yes because you need to map G at the
second level if you just had G on the
first that's why I'm putting map G no I
say the second and then F acts but for
example how do you know whether G or F
were used before okay so one thing that
should be true is that it should be
possible to write out everything
explicitly is it true that that is is
this true that if you want it at level n
that you have to say map a map of
whatever to n levels is that true or is
that nonsense you would have to say can
you achieve that by saying map of map or
not no that's why I created this map
operator form in the next section
examples a map operator form that takes
the level spec I know that for example
yes that the last line it uses it and
you see how it's being mapped right
because there were two O's okay Seth is
pointing out the query is really some
kind of multi-level function I don't
quite understand that statement um I
think it's it's like in the same way
that part acts at different levels when
you say part 2/3 so query is able to do
different things at different levels I
see what you're saying I see what you're
saying but part part is that it doesn't
matter in which order because things are
rectangular and they are independent so
the 203 act independently but when you
have query of F comma G then the problem
stop there is F acting before G or G
before F or F at the level in which G is
or which is right
well that's because right okay so part
is inert li extracting things whereas
this query thing is acting and
proceeding I mean it's similar to map
which doesn't see what it did it just
goes on doing stuff is that a true
statement no I understand that but I
mean if I say map level you know to
level infinity it's gonna make F of F of
F of F whatever but the thing that it is
mapping on it's kind of like in a
cellular automaton you're always
applying to the previous values you're
not applying to values that have
partially been evaluated did that make
any sense I mean so in other words with
a map you know even if you're ending up
with a heavily encrusted F of F of F of
F of F thing nothing evaluates until
you've already created that structure
yeah yeah right right exactly
so in the case of query are you telling
me that that I have to think about it
not doing that that is it has not
created a symbolic thing
which then goes through and gets
evaluated or is that not correct right
but you could write it as a pure
symbolic expression that then just runs
the evaluator
isn't that true I think we should know
the answer but I don't know the answer
but I mean that that's a so right
because I mean I think that would help
in documenting it if everything that you
could do with query was something that
corresponds to just a symbolic
expression fully written out it's always
possible to write it as this equivalent
composition of things that is the normal
of query okay so query you for example
not example via query F comma Sigma 3 it
gets converted into this part extraction
compose with Jung with F and that sort
actually acts on expression okay okay
fine so things happen what would you say
it acts on the expression oh I see so
there are these weird things like that
map yeah okay I get it I get it so I
mean so that's at least good okay so
then the let's post composing with F
there okay so question what what things
are being you know exude from general
utilities to be able to implement query
well we should we should consider making
those system functions because that way
this thing can have a much less obscure
life
I like this conversion of cording to
this normal in quotes expressions yes I
think that's very good yeah but so now
in the descending ascending business
that's going to affect whether these are
post applied or pre applied is that
correct when I was in this section
called how to explain things yeah yep
yes look at the last thing there so when
we have query select of a criterion
comma F you see the selection criterion
comes first and then the mapping of
death however that's a special select if
we had placed a function called cell
come up F you see they are reversed and
that's because arbitrary functions are
ascending while select is descending so
it's placed first
right so when Tali and I were working on
this okay there was going to be a rapper
called descending right that we could
put you know that we could wrap around
things to determine that but honestly as
we try to explain that it was
unexplainable but maybe we just have to
have we mean to put more effort into
that we need to actually come up with
the right language to explain it is that
this is difficult to explain because
there are two things involved I wrote
that in the previous section so there is
the thing of where things are applied
yes and then in which order and because
both depth and time are one-dimensional
both have different things
okay so in terms of the which level
isn't that done by slots in the query it
is but sometimes a function acts on the
elements of the next level
sometimes a function on the level of in
which it's placed so in the query
sequence each function is at a given
place it's a given slot but you're
saying that slot can be like like for
example total would be sort of a look
ahead is that true or is that not
correct yes I understand what I'm asking
I'm asking are you claiming that the
level can be somehow a look ahead the
function can be somehow a look ahead
level the thing that looks ahead of the
level it's on or not are you not
claiming that yes I understand but but
doesn't it have to be map of F to apply
to the elements but if you say F comma
all it's just gonna be around the whole
thing right yes so if I would say you
know data set of array a 333 for example
okay okay now I'm going to say for that
I want to say F comma all oh boy oh that
that's doing exactly what I would expect
that's the equivalent of this which is
yet the equivalents are just saying F of
a thing but now if I say all comma F
then that will be essentially the map
that's equivalent presumably if I'm not
mistaken to saying here a map of F okay
I have no idea
some kind of algebra thingy and it's
it's certainly not relational algebra
but it's some kind of other functional
algebra type thing that all these things
somehow I mean all these equivalences
and so on as some something that I don't
really understand um is the fact that we
have the general case for sending
operators but then the actual most
important cases used are the special
operators which we condescending yeah
okay but you're saying that's an OP
order of operations and there's also
other things so so um Seth is pointing
out that in his book he suggests that
people run normal which sounds
reasonable they also various detailed
comments here okay let's read through
this a little bit here sander is saying
it would be great to select could have a
level spec I thought select did have a
levels back oh you mean that that it
could say oh that's interesting yeah
okay that's select
could apply itself at level two for
example I mean that's the cool of the
maps select I'm a little bit unconvinced
I mean the only value of having would be
something where it say hey I'm I'm on
can risk I think you can think it it's
you know you end up having to say map
select pretty much anyway um okay query
has options that deal with failure um
South says query has three options that
are not preserved when you normal the
query okay it's interesting I see
because normal has a different form oh
boy you know I have a I have a terrible
recollection that I wrote some of these
um under duress I might add because I
thought they were very complicated it's
complicated to explain this gosh I'd
gotten this whole business about failure
action I wonder if we have a
defaults there all right but let's come
back to your original question or point
which was enumerated the the general
utilities stuff that query uses and then
figuring out if we can top a level of I
it alright so let me understand this
first what do we believe in the term
head map
it just sounds very obscure it's Sam I
was wondering whether this new point of
view offers some alternative which new
point of view they use inside you will
see the example at the intersection um
sorry whoa where are we looking so there
is some strange notation in data set
right now with this Association the
previous input the one which means they
are it's taking elements of column C and
then it's computing both total and
length and returned them in an
association yes but it's confused it's
it's composing a function with an
association which I find strange I
understand so this is the equivalent
okay so what you're saying is that the
head bap case of that yeah that's pretty
cool actually
that's pretty cool so that's a function
of operation we need for that precise
operation so let me review again what
head map does in the simplest cases okay
so head map
what does this do I'm just not
remembering a little mix a list takes a
list
so it would be f camac smoker fine it's
just with the sets the second argument
is naturally a list but okay so I will
seem it's tallies name apply through and
through the very bizarre not functioned
through it's very similar to this right
so I mean through of the list F G
applied to X gives that Association
Association would immediately try to
look for the key X sure I'm not I'm not
a big fan of this anyway I think it's
perfectly fine to give a I know if we
could only get a good name for head map
all right so let's understand again what
it's doing it's taking some functions
it's taking a list of functions or an
association of functions
around simply reversing it to map heads
I don't know where the heads are they
being up mapped onto are they being
because they're the ones doing the
mapping and I don't know why I mean it's
always mapping heads yeah I understand
okay so okay what we've got to
communicate is that it's hello guys um
some of these are
to overbearing head map is just weird
head mappings exotic it reminds me of
headdresses it is related to our weird
headdress concept I think as soon as
we're in headdresses we're in you know
just I don't know what um okay what is
really going on what does it what is
that what is the thing going to say
about head nap what is it gonna say it's
gonna say something like a head map of
this thing here um it's gonna say it's
not mapping its supplying isn't it no
it's it's not it's not doing either of
those its constructing right it's the
equivalence of construct F comma X and
the reason it was called head map is
because we're thinking of it as being a
backwards mapping which is extremely
obscure
I'm not particularly keen on this what
other functions this is silly this
reminds me of the cotton Jenny or
something I don't know what sorry I'm um
and by the way I shouldn't probably
called list because it also works with
associations do you know that in the
weird world of SMP apply was AP and map
was M AP which in the absolute weirdness
of short names I tried to claim was
multi apply excuse it's curious its
exotic it's crazy and it's not useful
here pretty weird
sounds like look it sounds simple which
is always good
whereas head nap just sounds exotic
by the way cephus is commenting on the
livestream about to UM getting more
things with interpreter to work locally
we are well aware and this is a project
very much underway um to get a local
version of most of the world now for
positive technology um although Seth is
commenting my interpreter after
transpose can sometimes fix the problem
because you only need one call um
yeah every we're well aware of this it
got slowed down it's good that now off
malphur is running inside Alexa but
takes time to make that happen
hantum that was um
um
yeah um
okay let's
suggested constructs plural but I don't
think that's a winner um okay let's
explain again what this does okay um
okay so it makes a list
yeah F of G G of X etc
you
of course there's another point of view
the other point of view would be to make
it actually a headdress and to say
something like this is kind of crazy at
some level but something like this and
have that become F of G f of X G of X I
mean that seems like it might actually
be quite useful well we could make the
non operator form you know whatever the
name is could be based on the operator
form ethan is suggesting using through
the second argument we unfortunately
already have a second argument which is
the head which is a mess that's just
horrifying what that did there I don't
think this is crazy I think there's
something useful here so now the only
question is what would we call the thing
that essentially Auto unpeel zit self
well it's kind of Auto threading Auto
threaded that's an ridiculous name right
so well no no no I understand I'm just I
don't like the name multifunction
let's see
Sothis commenting that we have a same
issue with grammar rules grammar apply
and so on
um oh I with respect to his slow down
we're we're aware where we're being
worked on um convective what does that
even mean
was the word conflict mean hello and
confectionary which I'm sure this isn't
does sound sweet are we about
cover okay why is this taking so long my
gosh
make or construct wowie well I learned
something new here Wow okay
I think this does not satisfy the
property that people learn about it from
the English word um yeah unfortunately
the thing about list function list
function unfortunately it's not a
function function it doesn't have well
okay I wish a multi wasn't a non
standalone word
I mean if the primary
for masquerade mean this is a nice thing
to have curried actually really quite
nice I can see that being quite useful
in a lot of situations well it's only
the name here that we that we're dealing
with and I need to run off in a moment
here I had to leave hold on one second
let me check yes I really do um-hmm by
the way there was a there was a thing
about having this meeting on a bi-weekly
and I I think with this one we should
follow up on um sooner but I can we can
you for next time expose what what is
sliced okay which is using the fact that
part has is is virag we at some point
ruled out map list for this name we
didn't rule it
would keen on it yeah we're mapping a
list of of things onto onto some
argument
so we're mapping the list FG Ethan is
commenting on the verb noun vs noun verb
I know in a you know it's one of those
this where the only perfect form is a
form that has it just there are cases
where it has to be one way or the other
and it is really you know if we could I
think even with a time machine we
wouldn't be able to do much better is my
claim I don't think that there's a a
uniformly consistent way of doing it
that doesn't lead to confusion
yeah image resize versus highlight image
that is indeed quite horrifying um
sandra is saying function goes to list
function
analogize that to fold and fold list
okay what is the analogy this so
no those ones are outputting a list this
one
last function
you
see what bothers me about this is I
think about nearest functions and all
kinds of things weird things like that
but in a sense it is a function yeah no
I know but that some of these things
that uses options but but let's ignore
that for a second um um
somehow lists for
just doesn't have the right ring to it
although I agree it's not obviously
awful
description
let me ponder this and the next time
let's let's talk about query more
seriously and let's talk about all the
other cases for query what one thing
about list function we could get away
from the association with things like
nearest function if we PluralEyes it and
that might make sense in this case
that's utterly obscure then it becomes
list functions and you're listing things
um that gets really really weird
um
all right
got a mystery here um you think about
this trapped well okay sorry it's a
naming problem um however it is yeah
what else do we have that is it could be
illicit or it could be an association I
mean things like map a very sort of they
don't really discuss that I'm gonna
probably have to oil my officemate or
something okay I have to disappear sorry
um thanks guys and let's see Sushma I'm
gonna send this notebook I I've been
saving this in some weird place I'm
gonna send this notebook back to you
okay um and thanks all thanks for
calling the live stream and see you next
time